[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 alors depuis
le début de la semaine on vous fait
revivre les temps forts de l'émission Le
7 8 on s'intéresse ce soir au mois de
novembre à quelques jours de la Coupe du
Monde nous vous faisions découvrir les
coulisses de Clairefontaine mais avant
ça un petit détour par Thoiry et ses
lumières sauvages
[Musique]
la féerie est ton rendez-vous pour le
zoparc et sur place on retrouve tout de
suite Gabriel Gontier rebonsoir je
disais tout à l'heure Gabriel le
rendez-vous a débuté depuis quelques
jours et depuis le 30 octobre
exactement Grégory depuis le 30 octobre
et justement je suis avec Guillaume
tiffraud qui est le directeur
d'exploitation du zoo safari de Thoiry
pour nous parler de cet événement alors
déjà est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer ce qu'on peut voir derrière
nous et comment vous avez organisé cette
année les expositions sauvage c'est un
parcours dans les jardins du château de
Thoiry de plus de 2000 lanternes et
c'est un travail qu'il faut nous comme
en France au mois de juin avec la
préparation la rénovation des lanternes
nos ateliers et puis on reçoit à partir
de fin août des nouvelles lanternes et
on installe tout ça pour que être prêt
pour ouvrir fin octobre et alors
justement c'est la cinquième édition
comment vous faites pour vous renouveler
tous les ans pour trouver des nouvelles
idées alors en fait les scènes changent
on est dans une zone marine l'année
dernière c'était un thème totalement
différent on réutilise chaque année des
lanternes voilà on va dire en recycle
volontaire et on recrée des nouvelles
scénographies à chaque fois et puis on a
des pièces majeures qui peuvent venir
d'une année sur l'autre là on le voit
peut-être il y a des requins énormes
donc ça fait partie des effets un peu
waouh chaque année et alors il y a une
partie de la confection de ces lanternes
qui se fait en Chine par des ouvriers
chinois comment comment ça se passe des
artistes même plutôt je pense que
exactement c'est un archi noir en fait
qui vient de la région du Sichuan c'est
les lanternes traditionnels il nous sur
la base de dessin et de croquis que nous
faisons ici à Thoiry par nos équipes
internes il réalise les lanternes et
après nous sont transmises via bateau
ici et après nous il y a une partie de
lanterne aussi qu'on a appris maintenant
à rénover il y a quelques années les
artistes venaient ici ils ont pu
transmettre un peu leur savoir à nos
équipes et du coup maintenant c'est un
travail en partenariat entre eux et nous
alors Thoiry lumière sauvage c'est
maintenant un incontournable pardon du
zoo qu'est-ce qui fait que ça marche
aussi bien année après année c'est
devenu un vrai rendez-vous je pense que
ce qui marche bien c'est que le bel
effet qu'on se renouvelle on a des gens
qui viennent chaque année à chaque fois
c'est différent on en prend plein les
yeux même nous les équipes c'est
toujours une surprise au premier
allumage fin octobre donc je pense que
c'est ce qui plaît beaucoup et puis
c'est un moment qui est assez magique
qui dure pendant plusieurs mois
puisqu'on commence le 30 octobre et
cette année on va finir le 5 mars et
donc vous pouvez venir à différents
moments de l'année à au moment des fêtes
on a beaucoup de familles qui viennent
pour voir cette cette festival là aussi
alors là justement on est dans la
période de vacances scolaires vous avez
eu déjà de nombreux visiteurs qui sont
venus on a fait notre plus gros
ouverture sur les 5 ans voilà on a eu
plus de 7000 personnes le premier
dimanche d'ouverture ce qui pour nous un
record donc on est on est très
insuffisant c'est important pour les
équipes de voir que leur travail de
plusieurs mois soit apprécié et là on
l'a vu pendant toutes les vacances il y
a beaucoup de monde donc ça c'est
vraiment plaisant pour nous et ça veut
dire que encore une fois on a réussi
notre pari alors cette année avec les
conditions qu'on connaît la sobriété
énergétique les restrictions est-ce que
un moment ça a été remis en cause ces
illuminations comment vous êtes adapté
alors remis en cause non c'est quand
même bien posé les questions encore une
fois c'est comme tout à chacun l'énergie
c'est aussi important dans les budgets
d'un parc animalier mais depuis
plusieurs années en fait le zoo est dans
une démarche de protection de la nature
de d'économie de ressources donc voilà
donc c'est des gestes au quotidien sur
éteindre les lumières dans les toilettes
présences et nous sur le festival cette
année on consomme 20% de moins que les
années précédentes principalement dû au
fait qu'on a réduit nos horaires de
d'allumage et lanterne et puis 100% de
lanterne et des différentes langues sont
en live merci beaucoup Guillaume tiffrot
je rappelle que vous êtes directeur
d'exploitation aux eaux safari de Thoiry
et que ces illuminations sont à
découvrir jusqu'au 5 mars et Merci à
VOUS Gabriel Gontier aussi à Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude qui était présent sur
place au moyen technique Nicolas dandry
vous souhaitiez réagir oui oui juste
prévenir Gabrielle attention derrière
vous avez une tortue genre je sais pas
ce qu'elle va faire mais attention à
vous quand même
effectivement on va continuer d'aller
découvrir tout ça Nicolas et c'est le
moment tant attendu dans cette émission
ces nouveautés dans le 7 8 on l'avait
expérimenté la semaine dernière on va
jouer avec vous et d'ailleurs nos
invités sont même restés avec nous
Pauline et Audrey Lepère merci d'être
resté et avec vous avec quoi on va jouer
avec le nom des habitants des Yvelines
je crois c'est ça exactement
à travers un petit jeu entre nous avec
nos invités vous pouvez aussi jouer sur
les réseaux sociaux vu que vu que qui
nous suivait sur Facebook
LinkedIn ou encore YouTube alors
première question Grégory monte juste ma
feuille aux invités je n'ai pas les
réponses
je suis le seul à posséder les réponses
et on régit aussi dans les réponses mais
alors Grégory je sais que vous
connaissez la réponse à la première
question donc vous pouvez laisser
peut-être nos invités répondre à cette
question comment appelle-t-on les
habitants de Montigny-le-Bretonneux
ce qu'on a droit à un joker
la question s'affiche d'ailleurs à
l'écran vous ne savez pas je ne sais pas
bon Grégory bon vous pouvez donner la
réponse les inondant inhymondins et Igny
Montaine
deuxième question donc dans quelle
commune vivent les carillons et les
carillonnes
Grégory est-ce que vous allez la réponse
les carillons et les carillonnes je
serai plutôt parti pour une un des
carrières non non
je me suis demandé effectivement c'était
pas carrière
ce qui est sur le carrière sur Poissy ou
ceux qui dans une carrière tout
simplement carrière-sur-seine
voilà donc les carillons et les
carillonnes pour les pour les communes
de Carrières-sur-Seine la réponse
s'affiche à l'écran troisième question
comment sont appelés selon vous les
habitants de
Saint-Nom-la-Bretèche
de Westfield par les deux d'ailleurs
ça commencerait par un B non non
ils reprennent l'ensemble du nom de la
ville finalement en donnant une nommé
breteuchois et les seins naumaises
breton
ah oui c'est ouais il est il est
compliqué celui-là est compliqué
attendez le 4e comment appelle-t-on les
habitants de Toussus-le-Noble alors déjà
est-ce que vous savez où si tu touches
le nom peut-être dans les Yvelines
non je ne sais pas
à la porte de du territoire et Sonia
juste après 50 ans en Yvelines avec un
aérodrome sur l'aérodrome de tous un
homme une vie commune connue pour son
aérodrome alors selon vous comment
s'appelle les habitants de cette ville
non vous avez pas d'idée Grégory
peut-être autour de noble les Nords les
nobles il suffit de prendre le tissu le
terme du prix le prix Nobel et vous
mettez Nobel tu sois les nouvelles tu
soignes voilà donc très joli désolé
cette commune donc voilà et allez
dernière question dernière commune
comment sont appelés les habitants de
Saint-Arnoult-en-Yvelines ça je sais
55 ans
il va falloir je pense qu'il va falloir
intégrer des bonus dans dans ce quiz
d'une autre émission
alors un petit indice vous vous prenez
juste le terme
Yvelines vous prenez juste le terme
Arnaud et vous pouvez constituer du coup
le nom des habitants de cette commune
soit c'est peut-être un peu trop
compliqué non c'est plus compliqué juste
non vous séchez aussi bon les
arnolitains
si on peut afficher la réponse donc ce
sont les arnoldiens
alors j'espère que vous en avez appris
un peu plus du coup je peux me permettre
allez les gentils ça s'appelle les
personnes qui habitent dans une ville
c'est les gens de telle ville par
exemple les gens qui les de Poissy ce
sont les pisses
donc les habitants où les gens qui les
courtois pour le chener au concours
parce que le général Rocancourt sont
regroupés depuis quelques années
maintenant
bon on apprend on en apprend tous les
jours donc tous les jeudis sur la
culture
chaque semaine retrouvez le Vy P sur TV
78 very yvelinoise personne est
consacrée aux personnalités du
territoire Yvelines focus cette fois-ci
non pas sur une personne mais sur une
émission l'antisèche c'est le
rendez-vous culturel et qui vous propose
d'apprendre tout en s'amusant c'est
chaque mercredi de 20h à 21h sur les
ondes de marmite FM 88.4 l'équipe de
bénévoles a entamé depuis la rentrée ça
septième saison regardez un extrait de
l'émission l'émission que personne ne
sèche ça c'est le slogan le concept de
l'émission C'est un rendez-vous décalé
apprendre tout en s'amusant c'est ça
l'idée avec de la bonne humeur c'est le
maître mot oui c'est ça l'idée l'idée
c'est on va apprendre on va passer enfin
on va on va décompresser voilà on va se
faire une petite soupape de
décompression le mercredi soir entre 20h
et 21h on va découvrir des artistes
locaux on va apprendre plein de choses
sur la culture et surtout je pense qu'on
va apprendre des choses qu'on entend pas
partout dans les médias et voilà et
c'est ça l'idée c'est de passer un bon
moment et de retenir des choses qu'on
peut raconter par exemple le lendemain à
la machine à café
dans un reportage qu'on avait consacré à
l'émission anti sèche l'idée c'est de
poser son cerveau est-ce que tu peux
préciser voilà d'emblée d'emblée on
commence avec avec les petits dessus
mais c'est quoi l'idée poser son cerveau
c'est à dire déconnecter comme le disait
comme le disait Julien et voilà
apprendre en s'amusant c'est c'est
complètement ça c'est à dire que ce que
je voulais dire par là c'est qu'en fait
on apprend mais en fait on sent même pas
compte qu'on qu'on apprend c'est
vraiment c'est du divertissement c'est
on s'amuse en fait tout simplement
derrière l'émission c'est joli prod
c'est l'association jolie prod on peut
dire aussi un mot sur jolyprox c'est
quoi joli prod alors jolie prod c'est
une association yvelinoise qui
accompagne développe des projets
culturels qui est là pour promouvoir la
culture locale et mettre en réseau des
amateurs et des professionnels et bien
l'anti sèche c'est ça reprend un petit
peu tout ça aussi à travers cette
émission on a la chance de pouvoir être
en partenariat avec des salles de
spectacle de l'agglomération pour offrir
des places aux auditeurs et auditrices
mais également on a un partenariat qui
est très fort avec marmitefem qui nous
permet de faire cette émission toutes
les semaines qui nous fait confiance qui
nous accompagne sur ce projet et voilà
et donc là le lien entre les amateurs et
les professionnels existent vraiment et
voilà un joli prod c'est ça tout
simplement
on est tout proche de cette ce 30e
anniversaire de de Déclic Théâtre
compagnie fondée en 1993 par Alain
Degois et Jean-Baptiste Chauvin on
rappelle les grands noms qui ont débuté
forcément il y en a beaucoup un Jamel
Debbouze ça va Marno de sa mère Issa
Doumbia Laurie Péret Matthieu Longatte
pour ne citer pour ne citer que c'est
dans un coin de votre tête déjà 30e
anniversaire
alors pour l'instant je vais vous dire
la vérité c'est vraiment dans un coin de
la tête on le sait que on va devoir
faire ça mais après on a une activité
très riche et très palpitante de manière
assez quotidienne cette année on
accueille les Mondiaux aussi
d'improvisation junior ça sera ça la
première semaine de des vacances de
février donc voilà il va y avoir des
événements comme ça donc oui on est déjà
un train de mettre les premiers les
premiers jalons mais mais pour l'instant
on n'a pas encore voilà on y travaille
et puis quand ça sera le moment de
d'appuyer sur le champignon on saura
faire plonger dans la féerie du comte de
La Belle et la Bête au château de
Maisons-Laffitte la société de
production Polaris organise un spectacle
immersif avec 8 décors de cinéma vin
comédiens 24 danseurs et 500 bénévoles
Mathilde Franco et Julien Leroy ont pu
assister à l'une des répétitions
générales
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était une fois dans un pays lointain
un jeune prince qui vivait dans un
château
et quelques mots vous disent peut-être
quelque chose la société de production
Polaris revient dans les Yvelines avec
un tout nouveau spectacle immersif sur
le compte de la Belle et la Bête au
château de Maisons-Laffitte en plus des
décors et des costumes on invite les
spectateurs à se glisser dans les scènes
donc c'est des espaces qui sont parfois
un peu étroits un peu petits on va
passer par des escaliers secrets en
colimaçon des lieux que le public ne
visite habituellement pas c'est un
château qui nous permet vraiment de
faire vivre le conte de la Belle et la
Bête en fait voilà les espaces
s'adaptent très bien à ce compte par
exemple la salle de Bâle qui est très
très belle avec avec ses lustres etc au
total 500 volontaires et comédiens
professionnels seront présents pour vous
plonger dans un univers féérique pour
rendre la magie possible il y a plus de
six groupes en fait de comédiens d'une
centaine de comédiens qui vont se
relayer du matin jusqu'au soir le
spectacle commence à 9 heures il se
termine la nuit il ne s'arrête jamais
[Musique]
cuisines et je donnerai pas mon rôle
c'est une surprise comme ça ça vous
invite à venir voir le spectacle pour
moi c'est une première j'ai fait un peu
de théâtre et j'aime ça d'ailleurs mais
c'est la première fois que je joue pour
Polaris et je pense pas que ça soit la
dernière je vis un rêve de petite fille
c'est à dire que je vais danser pendant
le bal avec La Belle et la Bête et pour
moi c'est exceptionnel c'est je pense la
seule fois de ma vie où je pourrais
danser dans le château de
Maisons-Laffitte en partenariat avec le
Centre des monuments nationaux le
spectacle aura lieu sur quatre semaines
du 18 novembre au 18 décembre l'occasion
de vérifier si le vécur bien heureux
pour toujours
[Musique]
on en parlait en début d'émission le
Movember ce mois pour sensibiliser au
cancer masculin Freddy Payard vous êtes
connecté avec nous à distance bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes ambassadeur de ce
mouvement qui existe depuis 2023 un
certain nombre d'années quel est son
impact aujourd'hui est-ce que il y a de
plus en plus de dépistage grâce à ce
mouvement
donc en fait le mouvement il a été créé
en 2003 en Australie
et donc il est arrivé en France en
2011-2012 donc c'est assez récent on
connaît beaucoup octobre rose pour les
femmes les cancers féminins en octobre
on connaît beaucoup le Téléthon et entre
les deux il y a le mois de novembre qui
est dédié aux maladies masculines donc
en fait mauvais beurre c'est une
communauté de Rockstar qui récolte des
fonds qui se mobilisent pour faire
bouger les choses en termes de santé
mentale prévention du suicide et dans la
lutte contre les cancers de la prostate
et des testicules donc l'idée avec la
moustache c'est de faire prendre
conscience aux personnes d'aller se
faire dépister et parce que c'est encore
des sujets qui sont tabous chez les
hommes
[Musique]
après le succès de la web série
osef car assemblé plus de 350 000 vues
sur Youtube le réalisateur Benjamin
palier s'est lancé dans la réalisation
d'une nouvelle web série intitulée au
KLM Céline Charlat a assisté à un
tournage d'un des épisodes avec les
élèves du collège Sainte-Thérèse à
Rambouillet regardez silence moteur
ah non prise 2
et action l'équipe de tournage du jour
c'est Stanislas Gaspard ou encore romane
tout s'inscrit au cours de pratique
cinématographiques dispensés au collège
Sainte-Thérèse de Rambouillet ils sont
10 au total et préparent une web série
appelée oklm avec leur professeur le
réalisateur Benjamin pallier originaire
de Rambouillet c'est une série pour les
adolescents qui a été réalisé en gros
pour les adolescents pour parler des
problèmes que peuvent
rencontrer certains adolescents dans
leur scolarité je joue donc l'autre rôle
principal c'est Enola on est les deux
personnages de la série qui vont aller
dans un kebab raconter leurs problèmes
aux autres
aux assistants aux assistants du kebab
qui tiennent le kebab donc on va leur
parler de nos problèmes et ils vont nous
parler de choses qu'ils ont vécu en lien
avec ces problèmes et ils vont nous
apporter des solutions tenir la perche
vérifier l'enregistreur faire le clap ou
encore le making of sur le tournage tous
les élèves ont un poste qui change au
fil des prises un cours avec un
véritable intérêt pédagogique il permet
aux élèves de découvrir les différents
métiers du cinéma moi ce que je préfère
faire c'est le clap
pourquoi parce que c'est un peu le truc
l'image du cinéma enfin quand on tourne
sur les dessins animés sur on voit
toujours le clap je préfère faire
l'acteur parce que en fait j'aime
beaucoup je suis très à l'aise à l'oral
et j'aime beaucoup faire ce genre de
choses j'aime beaucoup incarner un
personnage c'est de voir la progression
et l'effort des autres par rapport à
quand on filme à la première prise et à
la dernière prise qu'on prend et voir le
rendu final tu dis waouh pour les films
on voit vraiment que les acteurs mais
que derrière il y a plein de monde
pour tout préparer séparation des
parents harcèlement ou encore stress la
web série aborde des sujets propres à
l'adolescence des thématiques que nos
cinéasternes connaissent très bien je
fais une élève en cure de
désintoxication pour les jeux vidéo
parce que
c'est un peu que je suis addict aussi
dans la vraie vie je trouve que c'est
très important d'en parler parce qu'il y
a il y a plein d'élèves qui sont
concernés et qui peuvent avoir ces
problèmes là c'est ce qui se passe au
collège
les amis
qu'on parle de toi de leur petites
aventures du quotidien qu'on a vécu nous
aussi et donc même pour nous il y a un
côté nostalgique et donc c'est toujours
sympa
et Alexandre Gillet voit française de
Ryan Gosling font également partie du
casting la web série comprendra cet
épisode et devrait sortir au printemps
prochain l'association un enfant une
famille a permis à des familles isolées
de favoriser leur intégration et de
créer des liens sociaux et Gabriel
Gontier a rencontré Aurélie et Alice
toutes deux membres de l'association
regardez
[Musique]
toutes les deux semaines Aurélie
marraine au sein de l'association un
enfant une famille accueille avec son
mari Alice une fillette de 6 ans au
programme de la journée un atelier
maquillage pour préparer Halloween en
compagnie d'Elliott le neveu doré
[Musique]
ces sessions photos pour la filleule et
sa marraine Alice et aurélie s'empresse
de partager le moment avec les parents
de la petite fille tu veux faire une
vidéo à papa maman pour leur montrer
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'espère que la chanson vous plaît
voilà gros bisous à tous les trois
originaire du Rwanda en arrivant seul en
France les parents d'Alice souhaitaient
retrouver des liens familiaux pour leurs
enfants d'où l'importance de la
proximité car pour les vacances Alice va
passer quelques jours dans sa famille
d'accueil je reste chez ma marraine pour
dormir 4 jours
on va aller voir un parc où il y aura
des animaux une famille par extension où
chacun trouve son intérêt pour Aurélie
dans la maman a été famille d'accueil à
la zone toute son enfance cette avant
tout un engagement citoyen et une
aventure humaine moi je la vois vraiment
comme une comme une aventure
gagnant-gagnant c'est à dire que
évidemment on apporte à l'enfant
l'ouverture des activités qui ne connaît
pas forcément mais nous aussi on apprend
énormément et vraiment c'est ouais c'est
moi je trouve c'est une aventure qui est
vraiment gagnant-gagnant et je la
conseille à tout le monde parce que
c'est super chouette on vit des super
moments et puis c'est super enrichissant
[Rires]
[Musique]
après près d'un an passé ensemble la
famille d'Alice fait partie intégrante
de la vie d'Aurélie et son mari une
chance pour la petite fille car comme le
dit le proverbe africain il faut tout un
village pour élever un enfant au revoir
première question Jessica question pour
vous vous pouvez jouer bien évidemment
les invités vous qui nous regardez sur
les réseaux sociaux vous pouvez aussi
jouer alors première question et bien
tout simplement quand est-ce qu'a été
signé le traité de Versailles 1919 alors
oui mais alors je veux la date exacte à
la date exacte non c'était 1919
c'est en juin vous avez une idée de la
date non bon allez on regarde la réponse
tout de suite
28 juin
1919 bien Gabriel viens vous progresser
Gabriel alors je tiens à préciser il y a
deux personnes qui ont une licence
d'histoire autour de cette table voilà
donc on verra à la fin c'est bon
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au Centre national du
football de Clairefontaine je suis Éric
latronico le directeur du Centre ce site
mythique permet d'accueillir et
accueillir à travers les temps depuis
maintenant plus de 30 ans différentes
sélections nationales les différentes
équipes de France qui sont succédées
c'est pas loin de 16 à la sélection
nationale qui sont venus sur le centre
dont bien évidemment l'équipe de France
A qui prochainement jouera sa prochaine
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et maintenant on
va aller faire un petit tour sur le
centre pour pouvoir voir les coulisses
et voir comment l'équipe de France va
pouvoir se préparer pour cette Coupe du
Monde suivez-moi
[Musique]
et nous voici maintenant devant la
résidence de l'équipe de France cette
mythique résidence qu'on appelle le
château lieu de résidence de l'équipe de
France et de préparation évidemment de
ces divers événements et la prochaine
Coupe du Monde au Qatar et quand on
parle du château bien évidemment on
parle de ces marches ces fameuses
marches lieu de prestige puisque c'est
là c'est marche qui permettent
d'accueillir les joueurs pour la
première fois dans la résidence de
l'équipe de France qui vont pouvoir
découvrir ce bâtiment lorsqu'ils
arrivent sur le site
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le salon et mes Jacquet est un espace
qui permet d'accueillir les joueurs qui
est une zone de loisirs finalement donc
une zone d'échange qui est propice pour
créer le collectif où les joueurs vont
pouvoir passer du temps ensemble rigoler
discuter jouer donc vous avez un
baby-foot les joueurs aiment bien
pratiquer vous avez une table de
ping-pong également qu'on vient
installer ici et puis les joueurs aiment
particulièrement jouer aux cartes
également donc c'est un l'occasion pour
eux de se retrouver et d'échanger
ensemble espace ici les particuliers
c'est un petit bureau qui permet au
coach de pouvoir s'isoler avec un ou
deux joueurs pour pouvoir parler
tranquillement à l'abri des regards
préparer les aspects tactiques
techniques avec les joueurs à chaque
rassemblement dès lors que les joueurs
se retrouvent on va diffuser en boucle
sur les différents écrans que vous
pouvez voir
les derniers matchs de nos futurs
adversaires donc typiquement pour la
prochaine Coupe du Monde ce sera le
match de l'Australie dernier match de
l'Australie qui sera diffusé pour que
les joueurs puissent s'en imprégner et
puissent voir un petit peu comment
évolue l'adversaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chaque joueur a une chambre individuelle
qui lui attribué par le coach comme vous
pouvez le voir elles sont confortables
sans rien d'ostentatoire mais l'objectif
c'est que les joueurs puissent préparer
dans les meilleures conditions avec une
attention particulière sur la literie
bien évidemment pour que les joueurs
puissent dormir le mieux possible chaque
joueur a sa propre chambre et donc est
seul dans sa chambre
[Musique]
voici dans la zone de récupération donc
c'est un lieu essentiel évidemment pour
la récupération des sportifs parce que
cette salle elle permet d'accueillir les
joueurs et de récupérer après
l'entraînement de récupérer après les
matchs pour pouvoir être performant dès
le lendemain ou le lendemain donc on va
retrouver différentes zones vous avez
une zone ici technique avec des
appareils de musculation de cardio qui
permettent aux joueurs de récupérer vous
avez une zone également humide avec des
bassins un bassin d'eau froide et un
bassin d'eau chaude pour favoriser la
récupération entre les entraînements et
également une zone technique plus pour
la partie soin et massage pour la part
des kiné
[Musique]
chakra semblement bien évidemment il y a
toujours un passage par la case
conférence de presse et c'est
conférences de presse se déroulent ici
dans cette amphithéâtre faire en Sastre
de 250 places avec en contrebas
l'estrade où on va se positionner
l'entraîneur et les joueurs avec la
presse pour pouvoir interviewer
l'ensemble des protagonistes
[Musique]
nous terminons cette visite par le
terrain qui se trouve derrière moi qui
est le terrain
bibaro terrain d'honneur de l'équipe de
France avec une tribune de 500 places
c'est là où les supporters peuvent venir
acclamer l'équipe ça soutenir et puis
les journalistes également lorsque les
entraînements sont ouverts aux médias
beaucoup de joueurs depuis 1988 vous
avez quand même un grand nombre de
joueurs de haut niveau qui sont passés
ici ne serait-ce que pour citer Thierry
Henry par exemple mais vous avez
également pu récemment des joueurs comme
Kylian Mbappe comme Antoine Griezmann
comme Paul Pogba qui viennent
s'entraîner ici après cette visite nous
allons en terminer donc vous voyez
l'équipe de France va arriver
prochainement se préparer pour le Qatar
on va passer deux jours ici au Centre
national du football avant de pouvoir
s'envoler pour cette prochaine Coupe du
Monde et allez les bleus et nous
retrouvons un Mickael el midoro sur
place Michael vous êtes avec les
supporters quelle est l'ambiance sur
place
alors je suis précisément à côté des
supporters Mathilde les supporters sont
juste derrière moi ils font beaucoup de
bruit pour cette séance d'entraînement
la dernière avant le départ pour le
Qatar en entendu les irrésistibles
français en tous les champs à la gloire
d'Olivier Giroud Antoine Griezmann ou de
Kylian Mbappé ils sont environ 500 à peu
près aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines à la
claire fontaine pour soutenir cette
cette équipe de France cette équipe de
France qui du coup partira demain matin
aux alentours de 8h30 de Clairefontaine
pour la direction l'aéroport pour
prendre l'avion aux alentours de 10h30
mais joueurs français se sont ensuite
déplacés sur le terrain d'honneur qui
est juste derrière moi pour signer à
quelques autographes avec avec les
supporters on a pu notamment voir à
quelques mètres de nous à Antoine
Griezmann plaisanté avec les supporters
français ou encore Raphaël Varane ce
sera qui a dit qu'il était confiant en
vue de cette Coupe du monde demandé il y
avait bien sûr les stars qui a quand
même Benzema qui est Mbappé qui se sont
aussi arrêtés sont prêtés au jeu des
autographes et bien sûr des selfies et
là juste derrière moi il y a un petit
entraînement depuis quelques minutes on
peut voir un petit match entre les
remplaçants et les surement les
titulaires on sait pas encore mais en
tout cas un petit match bien sympathique
et vous allez me parler d'une initiative
originale originale du maire de La
Verrière oui effectivement je vous
propose de regarder tout de suite ces
images il y a le chapeau c'est un
bicorne orné d'une cocarde tricolore
vous avez aussi le pantalon avec un
galon de commandement puis la veste bien
ce sont les éléments qui composent la
tenue traditionnelle d'un maire du 19e
siècle Nicolas Dainville le maire de La
Verrière vient d'en faire l'acquisition
un costume acheté sur ses deniers
personnels je le précise auprès d'un
fabricant de tenue historique et on
écoute tout de suite le maire de la
verrière
là la branche d'olivier sur les
broderies qui symbolisent en fait
l'autorité civile on a des petits
boutons avec les lettres RF comme
République française une tenue de mer
qui en fait a été institué par un décret
impérial sous Napoléon III le 1er mars
1852 et ce décret n'a jamais été abrogés
c'est important dans notre période dans
notre époque de ne pas avoir peur de
notre addition
et donc on a compris le volet historique
Nicolas dandry mais à quelle occasion le
maire de La Verrière porte-t-il le ce
costume
avec d'abord donc une statue de la
mariée le maire qui entre dans une salle
avec la tenue et le Code civil à la main
on le voit entrer alors si je vous donne
ces éléments est-ce que vous pouvez
deviner Mathilde je pense que c'est à
l'occasion de mariage
qui est portée qui était portée déjà à
l'époque au 19e siècle par les maires
lors de mariage mais aussi lors de
baptême laïque hier c'était la journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés et empêché comme chaque
année la Commanderie à 50 ans de vie n'a
profité de ce rendez-vous pour organiser
une table ronde des journalistes et
auteurs victimes de répression et de
censure dans leur pays pour leur écrit
ont pu témoigner regarder ce reportage
de Julien Leroy
la liberté d'expression à tout prix
c'était le message qui était venu
partager les journalistes et auteurs
exilés en France autour d'une table
ronde à la Commanderie high en cours
dans le cadre de la Journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêché ces témoin mettez en
avant la répression et la censure subit
pour leurs idées dans leur propre pays
ce qui est inspirant c'est surtout le
parcours de ces personnes la résilience
le courage et puis ça permet aussi de
relativiser et peut-être de mettre en
avant la situation française et de se
dire que finalement ici on est passé mal
Simon sullimani journaliste kurde a été
emprisonné pendant 16 mois après la
tentative de coup d'État en 2016 pour
ses oppositions au pouvoir turc après sa
libération provisoire il quittait
illégalement le pays à la nage pour
atteindre la Grèce il est aujourd'hui en
France et continue d'exercer pour
alerter sur la situation en Turquie nous
avons beaucoup d'amis journalistes dans
la région qui ne peut pas diff les
nouvelles dans dans son sous ce nom là
parce que le gouvernement toujours
menace on prépare ici on diffuse ici en
sécurité enfin en fait France ça nous
donne cette chance de partager les
nouvelles Michael bachirov auteur de
théâtre et drainure russe subissait la
censure de ses œuvres en Russie il
faisait face à des menaces et
intimidation des services de police avec
sa femme réalisatrice un de mes
spectacles il était vraiment interdit
par la police parce que la police elle
est venue au spectacle votre spectacle
aux mille notre président notre état
notre société tatata et ça continuait
faire ce spectacle ça devenu dangereux
pour notre équipe la guerre en Ukraine
la poussée à fuir son pays avec sa femme
et son enfant
70 personnes étaient venus assister à
cette table ronde ce qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est c'est l'histoire de leur
parcours c'est la manière dont ils se
sont battus pour leurs idées pour leur
liberté et pour venir jusqu'ici moi je
me sens toujours un peu un peu
silencieux par rapport à de tels de tels
parcours en parallèle de cette soirée
ces intervenants mènent des
sensibilisations auprès des jeunes
autour de la liberté d'expression dans
les écoles 50 images
Céline vous nous avez porté apporté un
autre jouet un autre jeu pardon un autre
genre moi c'est pour les fans de karaoké
ou les fans de The Voice je pense qu'il
y en a autour de ce plateau qui sont
fans de cavaliers
alors c'est le Chabada comme le nom de
la chanson aussi c'est un jeu 100%
évelynois parce que il a été fabriqué
par la marque de jeu de société Cocktail
Games implanté à Versailles alors le
principe il est simple déjà il faut
faire une équipe faut faire deux équipes
de 4 à 50 personnes ensuite vous piochez
une carte il y a deux mots dessus par
exemple ici il y a marqué aimer ou save
c'est un mot en français ou en anglais
et en fait vous devez sortir des
chansons des extraits de chansons en les
chantant bien sûr un pas en les parlant
avec ce mot par exemple si je vous dis
le mot aimer quelle chanson ça vous
inspire on va s'aimer voilà
comédie musicale Roméo et Juliette
plus beau aimer c'est monté si haut
c'était ça les paroles c'est retour en
enfance et ben exactement du coup en
fait il s'agit de trouver le maximum
d'extrait bien sûr par équipe et il y a
une sorte de ping-pong qui se fait entre
toutes les équipes et au bout d'un
moment l'équipe qui n'arrive plus à
trouver l'équipe adverse faire un
décompte de 10 secondes et l'autre
équipe remporte la carte au bout de 5
cartes vous avez gagné le jeu vous
pouvez recommencer et il y a aussi des
petites subtilités il y a des cartes
challenge du coup pour pimenter un peu
le jeu par exemple il faut chanter avec
un accent de son choix donc refait
évidemment toutes ces chansons avec
l'accent québécois ou que sais-je donc
voilà c'est un jeu un peu amusant qu'on
peut faire un peu partout dans les files
d'attente dans les transports
[Musique]
le mois de novembre a également été
marquée par la rencontre avec de
nombreuses personnalités yvelinoise
comme le pâtissier Didier ledemais qui a
remporté le prix du meilleur pain au
chocolat ou encore le représentant de la
Chambre de commerce et d'industrie des
Yvelines Guillaume Kerrou nous avons
également rencontré le comédien Donald
réunion ou encore le rappeur
[Musique]
S
se sont éteints pour voir briller
quelques joueurs j'ai trop la haine tata
aussi je peux pas faire grand-chose
suis-je réellement prêt à passer à côté
de ce qu'elle va faire nous proposer
de ce que Mbappe va nous proposer moi je
me suis beaucoup retrouvé pour tout vous
dire dans ce passage parce que moi
moi-même étant fan de foot il y a cette
question en tant que fan de foot est-ce
qu'on va regarder cette coupe du monde
malgré ce dont on a parlé est-ce que
vous allez vous la regarder est-ce que
vous allez regarder peut-être les matchs
des Bleus ou justement vous allez vous
priver vous allez boycotter cette coupe
du monde alors soit je fais la réponse
MiTo soit la réponse sincère on veut la
réponse sincère faire non mais je me
sens beaucoup moins concerné par cette
Coupe du monde de plus en plus voilà ce
morceau ça fait déjà plusieurs semaines
qu'il a enregistré j'ai enregistré cet
été
ayant écrit ce morceau je vais pas
suivre la Coupe du monde à 100% même si
le fait qu'on regarde ou qu'on regarde
pas clairement aujourd'hui ça ne change
rien parce que que c'est fait c'est fait
donc maintenant je vais suivre de loin
oui j'ai envie de savoir quand même ce
que vont faire les Bleus mais je me sens
beaucoup moins concerné et moi c'était
une façon c'est pas ce que je veux dire
ce qui est important c'est que c'est pas
un morceau je l'ai pas écrit que pour
pour dire bon tiens je vais réagir sur
sur un fait d'actualité c'est aussi
parce que bah c'est ce que je pense tout
simplement et que et que moi voilà je
suis un petit peu dégoûté de cet
événement je vais suivre de loin mais
vraiment pas autant que que les Coupes
du Monde précédente Didier Le de le prix
du meilleur pain au chocolat de France
donc nous sommes allés à la rencontre du
pâtissier dans sa boulangerie à Poissy
bonjour trois pains au chocolat avec
ceci des louvertures ils sont sur toutes
les lèvres traditionnelles ou plus
travaillées les pains au chocolat
s'arrachent dans cette boulangerie de
Poissy et pour cause il s'agit du
meilleur pain au chocolat de France le
chef pâtissier Didier le 2 mai a accepté
de nous ouvrir les portes de sa cuisine
là on va découper les pains au chocolat
avec ce qui s'appelle une bicyclette
ça permet d'aller plus vite on va
pousser
dans notre sens
voilà ça soit bien régulier c'est très
important de la précision et de la
qualité dans chaque étape c'est
essentiel pour réussir un bon pain au
chocolat pour Didier le 2 mai ça passe
aussi par le choix des matières
premières comme ce chocolat venu
dardricourt dans les Yvelines moi je
pense que en France il y a beaucoup de
savoir-faire on a des
artisans on a tout ce qu'il faut en
France c'est ça d'aller chercher ça
ailleurs parce que la preuve c'est qu'on
arrive à faire des de l'excellence donc
si on n'avait pas des matières premières
de qualité on y arriverait pas des
produits de qualité et du savoir-faire
acquis grâce à 35 ans de métier mais la
vraie clé du succès est avant tout dans
la passion et l'amour du partage il faut
aussi avoir l'amour des gens pour parce
que faut aimer faire plaisir c'est tout
ça qui fait que vous arrivez à
l'excellence tous ces ingrédients ont
fait de la viennoiserie chocolat de
Didier le 2 mai la meilleure de France
successifs de pas de beurre pas de
beurre qui comme ça a été bien travaillé
vous avez un bon feuilleté donc un bon
croustillant et un beau et un beau
viennois
et vous mangez ça c'est juste magnifique
je m'en lasserai jamais tant mieux car
prochaine objectif pour le chef
pâtissier le concours du meilleur
croissant une chose est sûre il a déjà
remporté le cœur et le palais des
pissiakais
alors voilà pour vous j'ai réalisé cette
recette de petites pièces apéritives à
base de saumon fumé grenade pomme granny
une chantilly au curcuma les œufs de
truite vous les trouvez en supermarché
et les perles de citron vous les trouvez
sur Internet pour les professionnels
mais vous pouvez vous amateurs gourmand
vous les procurer bon appétit
Daniel est-ce que vous avez peut-être
concocté ce plat votre femme tout à
l'heure vous disiez qu'elle cuisinière
ça vous a donné faim le curcuma a plein
de vertus c'est vraiment un bon élément
pour le pour le santé pour la santé en
général une compétition comme la Coupe
du monde ça amène plus de licenciés
c'est toujours à l'issue parce que pour
le coup avec la Coupe du Monde qui est
placé dans cette période de la saison
donc du coup la saison est en cours
généralement c'est toujours lors de la
paire d'Estival et à l'issue de la
période estivale que les que les futurs
licenciés viennent au club donc là on
est dans un espèce de paradoxe néanmoins
je pense quand même qu'on aura des des
bons retours donc si la France performe
derrière on est probable qu'on est
quelques appels en plus et qu'on ne voit
voir peut-être avec nos partenaires de
la mairie pour qu'il nous donne des
terrains supplémentaires tant qu'on ne
connaît pas entrepreneur on ne peut pas
savoir de quoi il retourne et on a
toujours cette idée par les médias des
fois un peu déformés par le prisme des
grandes entreprises ou des entreprises
qui
le nombre d'entrepreneurs dans les
Yvelines c'est pas forcément
on a par exemple dans le département des
Yvelines on a par exemple 83000 microns
entrepreneurs si c'est 83000 micros
entrepreneurs sur les 130 000
entreprises sont accompagnées et qu'ils
peuvent embaucher un apprenti ou un
salarié Vous voyez on a on a créé 83 000
emplois donc vous pouvez pas besoin de
grandes ambitions juste un travail de
fourmis de terrain et de porter ce
message positif vers nos jeunes et vous
voyez dans la qualité d'aujourd'hui je
pense qu'on a un message vers nos jeunes
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas trop de
d'obstacles quand on veut devenir
entrepreneur on voit que votre parcours
est situé dans bûche
alors effectivement
l'entrepreneuriat vous mettez le doigt
effectivement c'est un parcours
d'obstacles et c'est un sport de haut
niveau et pour lequel il faut
s'entraîner sans cesse sans relâche mais
quand vous êtes dans un environnement et
un écosystème favorable et bien écoutez
on peut surmonter ces obstacles mais
effectivement créer une entreprise et
créer même ça petite entreprise c'est
quelque chose d'accessible à tout le
monde d'un côté mais en même temps de
l'autre c'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille c'est quelque chose de
compliqué mais la liberté n'a pas de
prix et c'est ça je veux dire qui est
intéressant dans dans l'aventure
entrepreneuriale il y a des
reconnaissances individuelles ça cette
coupe c'est parce que vous avez été élu
meilleur joueuse du match contre
l'Italie du quart de finale contre
l'Italie remporté 39 à 3 et vous avez
notamment fait cette action qu'on va
voir tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors 2 minutes de jeu on relance déjà
de son fond de terrain Émilie
de se rassurer collectivement et même
individuellement on s'était un peu
enfermé offensivement dans dans un jeu
de d'occupation au pied et je pense que
c'est nécessaire que qu'on se libère et
cette action elle a été le fruit de
cette libération donc elle s'est solide
en plus par un lycée pour Johanna donc
hyper positif et voilà c'était vraiment
du plaisir de de commencer ce match
comme ça et après il a été plutôt bon
pour pour l'ensemble du collectif donc
c'était c'était top les reconnaissances
individuelles c'est la deuxième fois
qu'on peut on peut le dire que vous en
recevez une parce que en 2021 elle a été
élu vous avez été élu meilleur essai du
monde dans le rugby féminin
oui c'était sur mon premier essai
international ma première sélection
j'avais j'avais le trophée du plus bel
essai et là du coup le trophée de la
joueuse du match sur sur le quart de
finale de la Nouvelle-Zélande alors
justement vous parlez de cette première
sélection c'est une première sélection
c'était en 2021 là maintenant vous avez
19 sélections vous avez seulement 22 ans
et vous avez commencé le rugby en 2017
c'est fou c'est une carrière en
accélération de dingue ouais ça a été
assez vite tout s'est vite enchaînés
j'ai eu la chance de faire des dès mes
premières années de rugby à des
sélections soit soit intercepteurs
régional etc qui m'ont amené à aux
élections nationales et après j'ai fait
j'ai intégré le pôle France du coup et
j'ai fait les sélections avec le set de
développement et je pense que c'est
cette discipline qui m'a permis de de
progresser rapidement sur tous les
aspects du rugby et qui m'ont ouvert les
portes aussi du 15 derrière pour pour
devenir international à 15 vous avez
commencé à Chilly-Mazarin en 2017 et
puis là vous quittez le cas vous prenez
votre envol direction dans le Sud-Ouest
exactement direction toute la région
toulousaine je m'en vais à Blagnac du
coup voir voir ce qui se fait de mieux
je pense dans le rugby féminin français
actuellement j'ai passé cinq années
extraordinaires à Chili ils m'ont tout
appris clairement on a on avait une
équipe incroyable
et voilà je pense qu'il était temps de
quitter le bateau de d'aller voir autre
chose de de se confronter à à meilleur
à plus de concurrence etc je pense que
ça me fera que progresser et j'espère
que ça m'ouvrira les portes de d'encore
de nouvelles sélections à l'avenir vous
avez sûrement déjà entendu sa voix
Donald de réunion et dans le métier
depuis 30 ans parmi sa va voxographie
Titeuf Andrew Garfield ou encore Jess et
zenberg et chose que vous ne savez
peut-être pas Donald Reignoux a grandi à
Bois-d'Arcy il est l'invité de Mélanie
poquet dans un nouveau numéro du vyby
regarde un extrait je suis tombé dans
petit par une un petit coup de pouce
mais j'ai entretenu cette chance et mais
j'en faisais pas une un objectif et le
doublage avait pas la la
visibilité tient maintenant
mais c'est vrai que c'est cool ça
parcours quand même atypique et puis par
le chant et pourtant vous chantez pas
souvent je trouve ça parle la Reine des
Neiges 2 c'est vrai que c'est pas mon
fort le chant ça me permet d'avoir des
rôles souvent chez Disney parlait
chanter mais je suis pas proprement
parler chanteur parce que je suis pas je
m'en sors pas les capacités donc en
comédien je suis capable de proposer dix
versions différentes par prise et qui
ont rien à voir en change je suis
capable de chanter juste ça s'arrêtera
là donc je peux pas interpréter plus que
que ça on est arrivé presque à
aujourd'hui mais au début vous dites des
chants des voix des semelles et le
premier rôle vous tapez quand même très
fort Andy Toy Story
c'est pas le premier rôle mais en tout
cas c'est le premier vrai rôle se lancer
effectivement
c'est vrai que le bouche à oreille après
ce film là a été énorme et voilà vu
qu'on est dans les Yvelines j'étais au
collège Mozart et j'ai arrêté le collège
traditionnel le jour de l'avant-première
pour partir en cours par correspondance
et il m'avait dit que que c'était pas un
métier de faire comédien donc
je peux comprendre parce que c'est un
métier qui fait peur c'est un métier qui
est qui est précaire moi je m'en sors
très bien et qui est très hasardeux mais
c'est vrai que on peut très vite avoir
des des longs moments sans travailler
donc je peux je peux comprendre qu'ils
étaient inquiet mais je suis content
d'avoir eu raison et de croire en moi
[Musique]
des lumières de la musique une piste qui
s'illumine bienvenue sur la troisième
étape de l'UCI track Champions League un
événement programmé pour la première
fois au vélo de route nationale de 50
ans en Yvelines et qui réunit les
meilleures pistes mondiaux avec un
objectif en tête pour les organisateurs
casser les codes l'ADN de Luc champion 6
c'est vraiment de fabriquer de
l'entertainment autour du cyclisme sur
fixe donc des animations à travers de la
nouvelle technologie on va conserver
exclusivement les formats les plus
impressionnants en matière de sport
toujours autour du cyclisme sur piste et
c'est vraiment voilà pour se démarquer
de ce qui peut se faire d'habitude et de
continuer à développer cette pratique
d'attirer encore plus de monde des
familles comme ce qui se fait en
Angleterre à Berlin d'attirer tout ce
monde-là en France et plus
particulièrement à 50 ans en Yvelines au
Vélodrome national au total plus de 3000
spectateurs sont venus voir ce spectacle
ce samedi 26 novembre le show il est
très bien ils ont mis de la musique il y
a l'ambiance avec les jeux de lumière ça
un jeu de l'habitude c'est mieux comme
ça mais je pense qu'ils ont trouvé le
bon principe pour faire vibrer les
spectateurs et faire venir les tous les
tous les passionnés de vélo dans les
vélos de drôles le public a pu voir une
victoire de la favorite locale Mathilde
de gros la piste qui s'entraîne dans la
structure c'est imposé face à la
Colombienne Marta Baiona en vitesse elle
termine deuxième sur le Kirin
[Musique]
c'est toujours des supers émotions en
plus il y avait beaucoup de monde donc
vraiment c'est cool ma famille toujours
au même endroit dans les tribunes non
franchement c'est ça fait que des bons
souvenirs pour toute ma vie quoi Lucie
trek Champions League devrait revenir
l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition au plus grand bonheur des
spectateurs
[Musique]
et les deux barriques en fait de style
de Bari sont vraiment la signature de la
distillerie c'est à dire que la valeur
ajoutée leur rapport aromatique est très
différent les barils de Bourbon qui ont
contenu du bourbon vont amener beaucoup
de rondeurs beaucoup d'arômes sucrés
comme un peu le caramel vanille
peut-être une pointe de banane et la
barrique de Bordeaux au contraire va
ramener des notes beaucoup plus sèches
beaucoup plus tanniques beaucoup plus
boisé
[Musique]
pour finir le plat la petite émulsion
une petite entrée d'automne
donc notre petite recette d'oeuf poché à
la gastache cèpes et girolles
ma petite astuce pour pocher l'oeuf
fermier
c'est d'avoir un œuf très très très très
très très frais
un mot de sport maintenant avec le match
de l'équipe de France qui va se dérouler
demain oui alors l'équipe de France
c'est déjà qualifié vous le savez c'est
donc l'occasion pour le sélectionneur
Didier Deschamps de faire tourner son
effectif le Piscia qui est Matéo gaine
Douzi milieu de terrain de l'Olympique
de Marseille de 23 ans devrait être
titulaire pour ce match et demain dans
l'émission nous recevrons à Guy Galanti
président du club de foot de morpa qui
vient qui viendra débriefer sur ce match
et cette émission best of est déjà
terminée on se retrouve demain pour une
nouvelle émission très belle fête de fin
d'année sur TV 78 et à demain
[Musique]